in a nation where food and electricity
are luxuries North Korea's leaders
believe this massive new ski resort will
rally the masses it took just one year
to build the latest pet project of the
regime's unpredictable leader kim jong
on jeongyeon she was our respected
Supreme Commander proposed this ski
resort project to improve our people's
lives the army started construction at
the end of July last year since then our
respected supreme commander has come
here three times to guide us in how to
finish it early we've done this huge
project that covers many square
kilometers and we're in position to get
it finished soon there's still no snow
as soldiers labor to finish the project
and there are no ski lifts that's
because Switzerland slapped sanctions on
sales to the north the resort has
reportedly been the top story North
Korean state television for weeks during
construction
there were many difficulties in
particular for the ski lifts there was a
big problem but we overcame all the
difficulties and the installation is
going on up at dae-hwa peak and soon the
ski lifts will be operational observers
say these lavish sports projects are
used by the regime to maintain its grip
on public opinion even as most North
Koreans are too poor to ever come here
the National Ski Association estimates
there are 5,500 skiers in a country of
24 million people the Masek pass project
is seen as a way for North Korea to
assert its agenda as Seoul prepares to
host the 2018 Winter Olympics yet with
patriotic posters proclaiming the
benefits of sports Kim jong-un may see
this as a way to deflect attention at
home from what the rest of the world
sees clearly a multi-million dollar
spectacle in a country where winter is
harsh and for millions of people a
struggle to survive
Zeb Eckert Bloomberg